yeah I changed my top again but you guys
know the truth this top is appropriate
because look well okay what up hi guys
welcome to tipsy Thursday where I teach
you how to do something tips are
involved etc education happens in some
way shape or form
today is the almost three-week
anniversary of camp Takota being
released yay medium celebration everyone
knows that three weeks is a very crucial
time who gives a
I just wanted to cook something with
tater tots today so I decided that I
haven't been in the kitchen for a long
time because I've been an independent
woman buying sandwiches instead of
making them invest in yourself so today
I decided that I was going to make a
food that celebrated camp Takota s'mores
and tater tots
great job me for answering my own
question so I decided to kind of combine
those two foods today and I'm gonna make
chocolate-covered tater tots but with a
kick and adding Tabasco sauce so I'm
calling these hot choco toddies but
basically they're gonna be spicy chunk
of covered tater tots and that could be
awesome or it could not and that's the
way we like it here on its grace just
like this hairstyle first thing we're
gonna do is we're gonna cook our tater
tops and you had to pre-heat your oven
to 425 degrees which I already did let's
get a tray whose tray
that's trash this is as close as I have
to a tray I'm only going to do half the
bag but when you do it always use the
full bag where it slips down I think I'm
going to spray this with Pam because oh
there they go
Oh five-second rule London Bridge please
go in the oven for 20 to 25 minutes
commence when I put these in the oven
for 20 to 25 minutes or until they turn
golden brown they look pretty
I'm brown they're ready but I will trust
what that package says in the meantime
talk amongst yourselves here's a topic
everything that daylight savings is just
the Sun on its period think about it
so our tots have been in the oven for
about 15 or 20 minutes that sense alone
is like I can't have children in so I'm
gonna get started I'm bouncing my
chocolate I've tried to do this in
numerous videos before and it usually
always fail so let's see what happens
this time where are the pots
I just watched the pot plenty of water
so like I've said in other videos where
I've tried milk chocolate I've seen on
the Food Network that you have to temper
chocolate I thought you only temper a
mattress tempur-pedic so you have
boiling water once the water is boiling
you put a glass or some sort of bowl on
top of it and then you melt the
chocolate in that bowl on top of the
water because of I don't know people
want to make cooking seem more
complicated so that when they do it
right they seem awesome now I just have
to let the water boil talk amongst
yourselves the topic is do it for like
um
the other daylight savings is the moon
on screen I change my mind I'm gonna put
butter in it just I don't know oh it is
working though oh that's fun it's when
you set out to do something and then it
sort of works
that's what filling I should hold on to
that feeling okay our chocolate is
almost completely melted and I thought
now I'll be the time to add the spice
I'm adding some Tabasco let's see if
this falls apart because I've made a
terrible choice ooh okay let's just add
a little bit too much okay let's blend
that into our chocolate oh no nobody
need to stop it because the chocolate
gets to tempur-pedic and then it gets
seized I've heard all these words on the
Food Network let's gather tater tots
I feel panic yes they feel both cooled
off in clubs let's start dipping Benny
oh it's Oh God okay that's kind of good
I guess
I waited the chocolate got you seized
mm-hmm I should've whacked paper I'm
just dipping half of the tater tots in
the chocolate these don't look very good
the tots are falling apart they do not
look like you should put them in your
body but we're all about taking risks
here on its grace that's a great one I'm
gonna put these in the refrigerator and
let them set up look at it doesn't it
look like faces with the brown hair okay
BRB chocolate what are we calling these
again instantly forgot hot chocolate
toddies choco hot toddies safe setup for
a few minutes and that's as long as I
can wait so let's get them they should
definitely sit longer in the
refrigerator but that's okay let's taste
one look at that it looks like a little
cartoon character with a cool scooter
Boyer put hairstyles in the
Peter don't world here we go
[Music]
not the worst thing in the world though
my palate is let's travel with less
chocolate yes okay I think that is good
it could actually do for more spice but
I think it's good celebrate camp Takota
with some choco
hot toddies oh wait camp Takota calm by
the film if you guys weren't following
along this whole time this is all about
this movie that we make on Camp Takota
[Music]